In those four years,
Toutatis traveled 8.5 billion kilometers.
That's a fractional precision
of 0.000000004.
(Laughter)
Now, the reason I have this beautiful asteroid fragment
is because, like all neighbors,
asteroids sometimes drop by unexpectedly.
(Laughter)
Three years ago today,
a small asteroid exploded over the city of Chelyabinsk, Russia.
That object was about 19 meters across,
or about as big as a convenience store.
Objects of this size hit the Earth every 50 years or so.
66 million years ago,
a much larger object hit the Earth,
causing a massive extinction.
75 percent of plant and animal species were lost,
including, sadly, the dinosaurs.
That object was about 10 kilometers across,
and 10 kilometers is roughly the cruising altitude of a 747 jet.
So the next time you're in an airplane,
snag a window seat, look out and imagine a rock so enormous
that resting on the ground,
it just grazes your wingtip.
It's so wide that it takes your plane one full minute to fly past it.
That's the size of the asteroid that hit the Earth.
It has only been within my lifetime
that asteroids have been considered a credible threat to our planet.
And since then, there's been a focused effort underway
to discover and catalog these objects.
I am lucky enough to be part of this effort.
I'm part of a team of scientists that use NASA's NEOWISE telescope.
Now, NEOWISE was not designed to find asteroids.
It was designed to orbit the earth and look far beyond our solar system
to seek out the coldest stars and the most luminous galaxies.
And it did that very well for its designed lifetime of seven months.
But today, six years later, it's still going.
We've repurposed it to discover and study asteroids.
And although it's a wonderful little space robot,
these days it's kind of like a used car.
The cryogen that used to refrigerate its sensors is long gone,
so we joke that its air-conditioning is broken.
It's got 920 million miles on the odometer,
but it still runs great
and reliably takes a photograph of the sky every 11 seconds.
It's taken 23 photos since I began speaking to you.
One of the reasons NEOWISE is so valuable
is that it sees the sky in the thermal infrared.
That means that instead of seeing the sunlight that asteroids reflect,
NEOWISE sees the heat that they emit.
This is a vital capability since some asteroids are as dark as coal
and can be difficult or impossible to spot with other telescopes.
But all asteroids, light or dark, shine brightly for NEOWISE.
Astronomers are using every technique at their disposal
to discover and study asteroids.
In 2010, a historic milestone was reached.
The community, together, discovered over 90 percent of asteroids
bigger than one kilometer across --
objects capable of massive destruction to Earth.
But the job's not done yet.
An object 140 meters or bigger could decimate a medium-sized country.
So far, we've only found 25 percent of those.
We must keep searching the sky for near-Earth asteroids.
We are the only species able to understand calculus
or build telescopes.
We know how to find these objects.
This is our responsibility.
If we found a hazardous asteroid with significant early warning,
we could nudge it out of the way.
Unlike earthquakes, hurricanes or volcanic eruptions,
an asteroid impact can be precisely predicted
and prevented.
What we need to do now is map near-Earth space.
We must keep searching the sky.
Thank you.
(Applause)